radar gun is going to be popping over in
miami glass now for the raise and sandy
alcantara an excellent young pitcher
starting for the marlins it's the first
of three it's the first of 162.
austin meadows steps in against the
righty now the 1-0 pitch and here's a
swing and a fly ball toward left field
over toward the line giving chase's
corey dickerson and near the line he is
going to get there and he
makes the catch right along the line and
there's two going here's randy or
rosarina
going after the first pitch fastball
base hit the other way
he got that one through the right side
so now
contour who has started all of these
hitters or that hard stuff did the same
with the rose arena you see how randy
right there was able to stay inside of
that fastball you know that was the
approach that we were talking about that
gave him so much success in the
postseason a year ago
oh and this one runs in and hits him
that's 97.
so diaz carries that with him the things
that can go wrong that fastball with
that much movement if you are going to
go in and make sure you get it in
owen to the count the pitch on its way
to kiermeier bounced in he's swung and
missed at it and the rays
are finished here in the first they load
him up with two outs but can't get him
in making his first opening day start
what he did a season ago leading the way
for the race pitching staff 11 starts
that 5-1 record innings pitch look at
the strikeouts
14.28 strikeouts per nine innings
absolute dominance as glass now ready
with a 2-2 swinging a ground ball to the
right side charging is the first baseman
yoshi chitsugo he's got it and goes to
the bag himself for out number one
here is starling martay
and he is out on strikes chased that
pitch and boy we're seeing some good
things here early yeah we've not seen
the curveball that was the slider and
look at the location this is what we're
talking about it opens up a different
location for tyler glass now down and
away with the breaking ball chisholm 268
during the spring one of the highly
touted prospects for the marlins over
the last couple of years here's a swing
and a ground ball back up through the
middle and
this one is going to be handled by the
shortstop willie adamus to the right of
second and throws the first in time
adamus up the middle takes care of
chisholm junior defensive shift works
against him you have nobody on here's a
rosarian
chopper toward the middle chisholm is
there to
make the play and the throw to first
underway in the fourth and first pitch
brandon lyles drives one into the right
field quarter that's a base head a long
run for duvall to try to get it for
getting the warning track low on his way
to second and the throw is not in time
it's a first pitch lead-off double for
brandon lau
a two-base hit for brandon lau jumping
on that first pitch and just like that
the rays have a runner in scoring
position both of these starters have
really settled in and so who's going to
crack first there's a pitch right out
over the plate lead off double brandon
lau leads away from second two balls two
strikes and one out in a scoreless game
and another strikeout for sandy he's got
four one in each of his innings thus far
now that change up again three
consecutive changeups to kiermeier
girmeyer fool great pitching matchup
tyler glass now on the hill for the race
sandy alcantara on the hill for the
marlins giving up just one infield hit
that's it
how about that i mean that's working
over a good hitter
he strikes out martin
fastball up and in for the first strike
fastball down and away cold for strike
two and then how about the hook the 12
sixer at 84 miles an hour to put him
away hayes and marlins no score here in
the top of the fifth inning of the pitch
here's a swinging little thumber out to
the left side of the infield charging
third baseman brian anderson his throw
to first is in time for out number one
brian anderson a gold glove finalist
last year
it's his first action today it'll be a
2-2 and there's a swing and a miss
meadows could not catch up to the
fastball and the rays
get a base runner but can't do anything
with it so with two outs of the bases
empty no skill here's yandy diaz and the
first pitch he takes a look at grounds
it to the left side shortstop
miguel rojas has it he throws across and
the raves go quickly and quietly here in
the sixth it's a great way to start the
2021 campaign six scoreless couple of
hits seven strikeouts now the o2 pitch
on its way swinging the ground ball
right side right there brandon lau is to
able to scoop it up and it'll throw to
first base and it's another one two
three inning
for tyler glass now well tyler glass now
could not be much better than he has
been tonight through six innings the
only hit ball hit by jesus aguilar
the
chopper with the toss to first
and kier meyers out number one austin
meadows up here now this would be a good
spot for meadows to connect you're gonna
need somebody to come through because
we're scoreless in the eighth middle
swings and drives one high in the air
right center field did he get enough
back towards the wall is duvall
looking up and it is gone home run
a two out homer by austin meadows and
here in the opener the race first run
has given them a late inning lead one
nothing raised boston meadows at four
homers during the spring picks up number
one right there first run of the year by
the rays gives him a late inning lead he
was able to launch that baby deep farro
struck out against glass now and
grounded a second against blast now who
gets a no decision same for alcantara
the marlins for that matter but both
just outstanding at their best
hard hit up the middle lao gets to it
but will not have a play not sure if
that caught the mound or fairbanks but
either way a little extra english on
that one
and alfaro is aboard with one out in the
eighth oh a nice swing by alfaro's
breaking ball a little bit away does
catch fairbanks on the left foot 104
miles an hour off the bat impressive
swing
so the old action pitch kiramar will
take off from third adamus from second
cenino from first
now snivers pitch on its way swing and a
ground ball to the left side that's
fielded by the third baseman anderson
he'll race to the bag and get there just
ahead of adamus
and that will
retire the side
argo put together a nice fight but
in the end
five unassisted on the fielder's choice
and now diego castillo enters from the
bullpen here to work the bottom of the
ninth
trying to get the three biggest outs of
the game as far as the rays are
concerned 22 games a season ago
a perfect record era of 166.
two out spaces empty 2-2 on duval
and the razor winners cut in the mist on
the fastball at 96.
and the rays
knock off
the miami marlins one nothing
to open the 20-21 season